So something as serious as the impeachment
of a sitting president really shouldn't depend
on yeah, on
public opinion.
Um, there have been a two impeachments of
presidents, Andrew Johnson and Bill Clinton.
Neither was ultimately convicted by the Senate,
but it's still really serious stuff.
If impeachment is the right thing based on
the facts, both Republicans and Democrats
should do it regardless of party and regardless
of public opinion.
Now that's idealism and it's not based in
reality.
It's not the system that we have.
Our elected officials are highly partisan
on what even is worthy of impeachment.
Uh, they're also completely influenced by
what the public wants at any particular point
in time.
And a really great example is to look at Richard
Nixon's resignation.
Nixon resigned because he was going to get
impeached.
He was going to get impeached because Democrats
and Republicans in his own party, we're going
to impeach him.
And there was bipartisan impeachment support
in the House and Senate because there was
more and more public support from both sides
for impeachment.
So that brings us to 2019.
And in Donald Trump's case in 2019, Republicans,
at least for the time being, still don't want
to impeach Donald Trump.
And Democrats do.
But support among independent voters has doubled
since May or almost doubled.
So, uh, since April rather back in April,
14% of independence said we should impeach
Donald Trump.
There's a new Marist, NPR, PBS news hour pole
where independent support for impeaching Trump
has almost doubled from 14% in April to 23%
now almost doubled in two or three months,
two months.
This is huge for two different reasons and
neither is that Trump is actually going to
be impeached and removed before the November
election.
He's not okay.
That's not the goal.
We should set our expectations correctly.
As I suggested we do a week or two ago, independence
doubling their support of Donald Trump being
impeached is huge because it's pushed total
supportive impeachment nationally over 50%
to 52% that is huge.
Okay.
This is starting to be a historical high.
52% of the country believes that the president
of the United States should be impeached and
removed from office.
That's massive and we have by and large independence
to thank for it because both Democratic and
Republican support for impeachment has stayed
roughly the same for several months.
The second reason that impeachment support
doubling among independence is huge, is that
it means independence themselves are moving
away from Trump for the 2020 election and
that could end up making the difference in
terms of who actually wins in November of
2020 because we know that Democrats aren't
voting for Trump.
Mostly.
We know Republicans are voting for Trump mostly.
I know that every election we say independence,
so they're going to make it, how will they
vote?
All of that stuff.
They're really going to be the difference
makers.
If support for impeaching Trump doubles among
independence, it is very reasonable to think
that just a few percent of independence have
shifted from a Trump vote for 2022 eight not
Trump vote in 2020 in the last couple of months
and that's bad for Trump in 2020 and I want
to backtrack one second here and refresh about
if impeachment conviction isn't the goal,
why is it that we want impeachment proceedings?
The whole point here is to publicize the content
of the Mueller report.
Okay.
The Mueller report found substantial evidence
that Donald Trump obstructed on eight of 14
counts that the Mueller report looked at.
We need public impeachment hearings.
We need testimony.
We need the content of the Mueller report
publicized.
We need all of it.
It will not get Republicans to convict Donald
Trump and remove him before November of 2020
unless something incredibly unpredictable
happens.
I just don't see it happening.
It will, however, pierced the echo chamber
of those who believed the entire bar letter.
No collusion, no obstruction, propaganda talking
point.
Most people in the Fox News bubble have no
idea how disastrously damaging the content
of the of the Mueller report was.
Because most people in the Fox News bubble,
and by the way, a lot of Americans in general
haven't actually read the content of the Mueller
report.
Impeachment hearings will expose that it was
77,000 votes in three states that led to Donald
Trump at defeating Hillary Clinton in 2016
those impeachment proceedings and starting
with the inquiry, most importantly, should
start right away.
And all of this information should be publicized.
If you think I'm wrong, let me know.